Finally, Dr. Connors, what's just one thing we should all ditch completely and replace with something
healthier today? Oh boy, I mean, you could talk about diet and you could talk about all that
kind of stuff. But I think, you know, with my journey in getting diagnosed with a cancer that has
a seven percent five-year survival rate, made me think of what's really important. And I would say
the thing that I'm working on ditching completely is judging, judging myself and judging others and
putting expectations on others and putting expectations on myself that God hasn't placed.
So that's just my journey that God's really working on me and ditching because I think that is
at least for me, maybe it's just me, where I am judging myself again. But...
Well, this reminds me of something I always say, you know, in fact, I included in my bio and my
website sometimes that I believe that health is simple, wealth is doable, but happiness takes
priority over both. Because, you know, if you get, I mean, health, it's simple, eat your veggies,
eat your fruits, you know, take your supplements, your fitness exercise. I mean, it's not that complicated,
but it's hard. And then, you know, wealth is doable, but it's not the most important thing in
the world. And with everything, like, don't judge yourself, don't judge others, don't stress yourself
out, you know, about eating the doughnut because your happiness should take priority over everything,
I believe. That's right.